[Applause]
from high-energy performances to
motivational speeches in this video
several points were made you want a
world where we're all treated equal to a
few things that left us sort of
scratching our heads et is taking a look
at the most memorable moments from the
2019 MTV Video Music Awards Liz oh got
the crowd fired up performing two of her
biggest hits the singer got so hiked
during her performance she took a swig
from a sparkly bottle and opened up to
et about it backstage we have one shot I
took the whole shuttle accident right
before my speech Dover so I would leave
so whatever was there I don't remember
the colorful vibes were strong with
Taylor Swift to perform two songs off
her hit new album lover
t-swizzle took home two awards she and
todrick Hall used their speeches to
promote acceptance and change your truth
with the world no matter what you
identify as half a million signatures
which
which is five times the amount that it
would need to wear
from the White House it was a huge night
for Missy Elliott who received the video
Vanguard Award
she put her thing down flipped it and
reversed it performing some of her most
recognizable songs
[Music]
it was also a big evening for lot Enix
artists including Rosalia and Ozuna bad
bunny and J Balvin and Camila Cabello
who up to the steamy Factor performing
alongside her rumored beau Shawn Mendes
[Applause]
[Music]
jameelah wasn't the only could be couple
there Miley Cyrus and Caitlin Carter
were also spotted backstage ahead of
Miley's performance and I witnessed lzt
the pair shared some sweet PDA moments
together they held hands and Caitlin
even put her hand on Miley's behind
[Music]
caught off the release of her debut solo
music video nor money tore up the stage
singing motivation honestly a dream come
true
I've worked incredibly hard you know
seven eight long years in preparation of
this moment and it's just really
beautiful because it's also the
beginning so I'm just really really
grateful for the opportunity even with a
little wardrobe malfunction the singer
carried on like the true pro that she is
I was honestly still freaked out about
the fact that the situation wasn't
working but I was like you go for it I'm
so happy you feel so proud right now
probably gonna cry tonight the night was
pretty smooth overall but there were a
few moments that were a little cringy
like when John Travolta appeared to
mistake Jade Jolie
for Taylor Swift on stage
[Music]